hey guys how's it going so today we're
going to be building some gingerbread
houses sort of I'm a huge gingerbread
house building fan so is Jenna and
there's Jase that's why she broke and I
was too slow ordering our gingerbread
and so I filling your graham crackers my
name isn't to be a really fun sister
brother challenge so you guys also have
a youtube channel yes those for others
and we're gonna try to build some fake
houses they build real houses over 10
minutes yes or don't for height yeah
height height or the towers height amo
debility ready go ten minutes on the
clock
Alexa that's ten minutes
we switch them on to your team I think
it's a variety wanna sweaty we should
sweat honesty did we switch cuz that's a
great idea
I'm sorry I know yeah what is this hold
on that is our base I thought we were
gonna start doing that right on key on
the next Oh
[Music]
what if we just like damn by we're going
to open another icing thing in a second
you don't think they got the idea that
just piling all the graham crackers on
top each other not the best way to go
for height work we have garters where
you have what do you have over there
sister
oh we got we can win we can win okay
fifteen seconds left
oh my god oh yeah four three two one do
not 2019 all right
what are you go back oh okay let go let
go looking like there you go yeah what
do you think this cake I owe that those
are I think it's pretty clear that I won
hands down hands up hey I got icing on
me
well I'm not really sure what happened
here silly this wasn't gingerbread but
graham crackers also work just as well
to build a graham cracker gingerbread
house what we learned is don't send drew
to pick up and losers Sean Penn and
Jenna have to eat all of this thank you
guys so much for watching be sure to
check out their channel to stop brothers
and Jenna's channel it's me Johnny and
you're already on my channel I just seen
and subscribe to all of them and Happy
Holidays
happy holiday
oh brother we were higher I know a spell
card which revived about the candy cool
a girder so I'm at the airport right now
if you haven't noticed this is probably
gonna be the best flight of my life and
it's also hopefully hot no we sold our
own places we don't get home a lot our
family and friends stay here more than
we do with a guest house next door which
we'll show you for our parents but we
just thought we call it the Scott family